a March 11th
an earthquake and tsunami sparked a
disaster at the Fukushima Daiichi
nuclear plant in Japan with cooling
systems knocked out three reactors
melted down in those first days the only
thing that military and civilian
authorities could do was to spray water
to try and prevent further damage to the
reactors today the immediate crisis has
passed
but Fukushima is still a very dangerous
place thousands of workers are currently
on site to conduct damage assessments
and cleanup operations in some areas
radiation levels are high enough to kill
within minutes workers must wear masks
and protective suits everywhere they go
here they're spraying suppressant to
keep down radioactive dust water is also
a major problem as it's pumped into
reactors that leaks out of broken pipes
and cracks creating a radioactive mess
around the plant and the contamination
has spread far beyond the site aerial
surveys reveal a plume of fallout to the
northwest of the plant when the crisis
began thousands living in these areas
were evacuated to temporary shelters now
some may not be able to return home for
decades the Tokyo Electric Power Company
has apologized to the people of Japan
for the accident but these maiya culpas
haven't gone down well with the Japanese
public TEPCO and the government have
both come under fire the Prime Minister
Naoto Khan resigned in large part
because of the response to the crisis
but there are signs of progress
TEPCO recently installed an elaborate
filtration system to remove radiation
from the water and workers are
assembling a cover over the unit one
reactor similar structures will
eventually be built around units two and
three and by winter TEPCO hopes the
damaged reactors will be able to stay
cool on their own without adding more
water in many ways Fukushima is a local
disaster but the impact stretches across
all of Japan
the country depends on nuclear for over
a quarter of its electricity and has
faced shortages since the quake plans to
increase its nuclear supply are now in
doubt Fukushima is the worst nuclear
crisis in 25 years and that means it's
also received global attention the
International Atomic Energy Agency has
visited Japan to survey the damage and
other nations are reconsidering their
positions on nuclear power Germany has
decided to get out of nuclear altogether
while the US and China are undergoing
lengthy safety reviews back at Fukushima
what's going to happen in the long term
is still very unclear somehow the fuel
from these reactors will have to be
removed and the Japanese government has
vowed to clean up at least some of the
land around the plant one thing is for
certain the accident is going to stay
with Japan and the world for decades to
come
[Music]
you